hey everyone de Volo here and I think to
start off this massive video going over
every single curse technique instead of
the verse that we firstly delve into the
teachers of each school and their
respective techniques then work our way
through the rest of them from there of
course not every single person will be
mentioned because sometimes two people
might have the same technique and some
Sorcerers don't even have an anate
technique or inherited one also for you
disgusting anime only this will include
a bunch of stuff in the manga so you
have been warned getting into it though
and being one of the strongest people
instead of the verse rip the strongest
though satu Gojo is equipped with a
plethora of different abilities that
we've seen being used in a variety of
different ways firstly putting him
already a mile above the wrist Gojo is
born with these bad boys a six siiz bear
has immense perception and unrivaled
visual prowess far beyond that of any
other sorcerer the eyesight is
comparable to like a high definition
infrared camera and they can easily see
things from several kilometers away at
all times these six eyes are constantly
active kind of like a passive trait that
you're unable to deactivate weirdly and
I'm assuming because they're like a
physical body part the person was born
with they don't seem to actually take up
any curs energy itself more just placing
a physical burden on the user if the
eyes are uncovered for an extended
period of time the six eyes are without
issue able to observe the flow of cursed
energy gifting their user with the added
ability to read an individual's curse
technique and determine its function
they can even differentiate between
different types of curse energy which
and turn allows the user to figure out
who they might be facing the six size
also allows for the extremely precise
manipulation of curse energy down to an
atomic level this not only allows the
beer to operate the Limitless through
the complex control of curse energy but
enables them to process it with great
efficiency as well speaking of the
Limitless technique next up is obviously
Limitless at the base level and just
like the eyes themselves Limitless is an
innate technique which is passed down
inside of the Gojo family this technique
grants its user an almost absolute
control over an untangle space through
curse energy manipulation in turn
anything that approaches the infinity
slows down and never reaches the user
this is because the technique takes the
finite amount of space between the two
subjects and divides it an infinite
amount of times in maths no matter how
many times you divide a number it will
never reach zero instead you're left
with incredibly tiny fractional parts
that are almost impossible to measure
with our like basic human eyes now
imagine if we could bring this
mathematical concept to life and that's
pretty much how we get this insanely
broken ability of Limitless due to just
how brilliant and in depth of a
technique that it is Limitless has three
standard and one non-standard technique
Beyond this the first of these is the
curse technique laps or blow this
remarkable technique not only cranks up
the cursed energy output to
unprecedented levels but also generates
the power to attract this is achieved by
amplifying the Limitless and bringing
the conceptual impossibility of negative
distance into reality it's just freaking
mind-blowing those forces the
surrounding space try and fill in the
gate by pulling violently towards the
source of the previously mentioned
impossibility creating the magnet like a
effect plus I guess we can just Chuck in
the maximum output version of this
technique just to you know like pair the
already ridiculously long video which is
obviously you know curse technique
maximum curse energy output blue but you
know either way moving on to the next of
these uh three here the second of the
three is the reversal of Limitless so
unlike how blue played on the effects of
curse energy curse technique reversal
red is the opposite as it refers to the
effects of the strengthened technique
and brings the Divergence of infinity
into reality generating the power to
repel Gojo is able to achieve his first
use of it at his battle against toi
after he was physically pushed to his
limits so it just shows how like
technically hard it was for him to
actually achieve this this ability as he
said after he returned this is achieved
by flowing reversed curse energy into
the power of Limitless creating a
repelling effect that's over two times
stronger in comparison to blue of course
the reason he failed to use red
initially against the paper bag head
dude was because Gojo's application of
reverse curse technique or RCT wasn't
exactly there yet while we are here
talking about RCT I might as well
explain that reverse curse technique or
what I say a lot of the time RCT or RTC
cuz I go and mess it up technically
isn't a curse technique but a special
type of sequence that takes curse energy
and reverses it into positive energy
it's a very complex ability and is
mainly used to heal human bodies don't
ask me why it's not specifically a
technique I just know gig Alami came out
at one point and specifically said that
it wasn't a technique it's just like an
adaption of curse energy I don't know as
we learned recently reverse curse
technique also allows someone to restore
their exhausted curse technique however
it's important to note that you can't
simultaneously recover your physical
body and your curse technique it's one
or the other what I do find most messed
up like gig is actually crazy is that
rejuvenating a worn out curse technique
involves damaging in the section of the
brain where these techniques are
imprinted and then healing it using a
reverse curse technique BR another
ability that Gojo is only able to use
due to his six eyes is the advanced
technique longdistance teleportation
like the name says a limitless user is
able to use spatial manipulation to
teleport long distances although the
user can only teleport themselves
instantly with a hand signal this is
achieved by compressing the space
between the user's location and the
desired destination to teleport multiple
people the Limitless us user will need
to draw a sorcery Circle large enough to
hold the amount of people they want to
teleport lastly out of the techniques
only a limitless user can achieve and
another Advanced one we have the Holo
technique purple like I mentioned before
red and blue make up both the first main
two abilities found within Limitless Hol
purple the third is the fusion of both
of them a secret ability only known to a
few within the Gojo family straight up
this has been said so many times like
now that we think of it but we still yet
to even meet someone else other than
Gojo from the Gojo Clan but you know
either way putting that aside this
ability represents the motion of blue
and the reversal of red a fusion of
convergence and Divergence that collides
both Infinities to generate an imaginary
mass that destroys anything it touches
which is actually crazy it's just you
know like gigo was like how can I make
something so broken that it destroys
anything it touches oh it's an imaginary
mass that would destroy anything it
touches so yeah fair enough it's
probably like plasma or something either
way next up and here is a personal
favorite of mine just to how many times
mppa snaps with every single application
of it in the series black flash as
everyone's surely heard so I'll be quick
with this one black flash is a
distortion in space that occurs when
cursed energy is applied within
0.000000001 second of a physical Hur
when a sorcerer is able to achieve this
the curse energy flashes the color black
and the destructive power of their
strike is equal to a normal Hur to the
power of 2.5 so to figure out whatever
that equals you just come and take what
a normal hits Chuck it in the exponent
calculator and you'll get the answer
that you want next up out of the faculty
that actually has an ability we can talk
about is the big man himself Masami Yaga
the 50-year-old man with a crippling
plushy addiction who actually has one of
the strongest in fear over abilities
inside of the series if you're higher up
unlike mjo's manipulation of curses
masamichi doesn't use people but instead
is able to infuse the dolls he creates
with a cursed energy core in order to
bring the inanimate objects to life and
control them with an incantation he has
developed a wide variety of different
cursed corpses including Panda sukamoto
Kathy and of course the little man
himself taku who you know chilled out
with Yuji while he was watching Lord of
the Rings the reasoning I of behind him
being feared over is actually because
the Potential Threat of a multitude of
sentient cursed corpses nearly LED all
of the higher ups to promote masamichi
to special grade but instead they place
an indefinite restriction on him meaning
that he wasn't allowed to create a
multitude of cursed corpses since that
point masamichi has kept his other
creations a secret within a forest
protected by tingen well these two have
kind of been fitting to stick together
if you know what I mean sadly the guy
who doubt the finishing blow to
masamichi yoshinobu gaku ganji had an
even more lethal ability looking like a
rockar and using a technique that we
don't know exactly the name of but have
an understanding of how it works gagu
gan's technique uses his body as a form
of sound amplification device amplifying
anything that he plays on his electric
guitar and in turn it launches a wave of
amped up El iCal curse energy at his
opponent next up and being an aid lover
of beer utahime and her ability comes
with no surprise solo forbidden arena is
an innate technique that creates a Zone
around the sorcerer that temporarily
amplifies the curse energy of any person
within range including herself solo
forbidden arena is not particularly
suited for combat as it requires
preparation time and is best applied to
enhancing allies I haven't mentioned
this as of yet I probably could have
with Gojo but I rambled on with some of
hisil abilities for a bit too long the
technique can actually be elevated into
a ritual using incantations hand signs
dance and music by including all of
these steps the technique's
effectiveness can be raised to
120% this however doesn't just work for
utaha all sers are actually able to
elevate their techniques with
incantations it's just more or less a
Time based thing during
battle so that brings all of the
teachers inside of jiujitsu Kaizen both
at Kyoto and jiujitsu Tech scores to an
end if I don't mention any specific
characters and their techniques it's
either because we haven't seen them use
one or they sharing one with another
character that I've already spoken about
like shoko kind of only has the reverse
curse technique and I mentioned that
there with Gojo but either way moving on
forward when it comes to Yuji he doesn't
have any inate or inheritor technique
however he is equipped with his own
unique effect PS yui might be like a few
chapters away from learning a curse
technique or he might even have it right
now or about to find out like two days
after I Dro this freaking video so if he
does end up having one it'll be awesome
to see him gain something in the end
like man's use Divergent f for how long
now and I'm assuming it'll probably have
something to do with body swapping after
that short section of him practicing
with kusak cab when it comes to the big
Divergent first itself simply a fugi
strikes with his first using a thin
layer of curs energy a second wave of
cursed energy is Unleashed a few moments
afterward effectively creating two
impacts with one punch this is as Cojo
said earlier on in the series because
Yuji is too physically quick has cursed
energy lags behind and takes time to
catch up creating that double impact
second out of the series main Trio Mami
fushiguro is stocked up with an arsenal
of shikami that originate from an
inherited technique passed down inside
of the zenan clan this is of course the
illustrious 10 Shadows technique this
technique grants the user the complete
manifestation of Shadows allowing
someone to hide in them or store objects
it also grants them the possibility to
summon up to 10 different chami using a
specific correlating hand signal and the
shadows as an intermediary between the
Shadow and human Realms when someone
inherits the 10 Shadows technique they
initially receive two Divine dogs from
which the other shikami can be summoned
with an exorcism ritual where the user
must defeat the shikami in order to make
them submit throughout the series we see
beg Mami throw up his gang signs a
multitude of times pretty much allowing
us to see all 10 of his chosen shikami
the first Divine dogs are a pair of twin
wolves that can comfortably take out
lower grade curs es after having the
white Hound killed by the finger Bearer
another application of the 10 Shadows
technique is seen when meami uses the
liquid remains to mix the walls together
turning them into one larger and much
stronger shikami the Divine dog totality
totality is strong enough to contain
with special grade Cur Spirit making it
one of megami's strongest offensive
shikami probably my favorite out of all
of his shikami just due to the fact that
it can fly would have to be no way no
way is a wing shikami with an extremely
high top speed and electrical Wings it
can help one person by carrying them W
flying to increase their mobility and
can attack with its heavy Wings charged
with electricity shocking anyone it hits
and leaving them temporarily paralyzed
in addition to basic offensive
applications noise speed and wings can
also be used defensively to Shield its
user from any potential harm third of
the known shikami toad is a large frog
shikami that can support its Master
using its long tongue I'm assuming that
you could probably ride it to or use it
like a stepping stone as we saw from the
armi but it's mainly seen using the
tongue its tongue can actually be used
to ins snare its Master's Target in a
tough hold and is strong enough to throw
those same targets around with its
tongue its large size also allows it to
carry injured humans in its mouth for
protection but like I mentioned the
biggest upside to the toad is the tongue
and its speed next up bigar roochi or
the Great Serpent is a giant snake Shak
kagami that can quickly attack and in
snare its users targets with an a
constructive hold the snake seems to be
more of of a sneake attack-- like weapon
as the user can use it to attack from
the Shadows at a high speed the Great
Serpent size also allows it to overpower
large curses possibly even swallowing
them in one go and it can also be used
to keep a Target in place while other
chicagami launch combination attacks on
it so not including H sakun and shikami
as we'll get to lose later on in the
video megami's max elephant is
definitely his most explosive shikami as
we've all seen the shikami is capable of
spewing large violent torret of water
from its trunk that are capable of
pushing back or even drowning the
intended target it can also be used to
crush its M's Target within its immense
weight however the cost of curse energy
to summon the shikami is huge in
comparison to others this in turn
obviously depending on like who has the
10 Shadows technique will allow them to
summon at once being a polar opposite to
Max elephant meami 6 shikami rabbit
Escape is a massive swarm of rabbit like
chagani that serve as more of a
distraction for the user than an attack
in itself upon activating the technique
teque dozens like I'm actually unsure
even if we get an exact number but a
bunch of rabbits fill the area to
distract the opponent allowing the
Summoner to escape danger or use them to
his advantage and attack the confused
opponent lastly the big man himself
mahara who I don't even know if I should
include as a part of the Teen Shadows
technique or talk about more with Akuna
but we'll just do him here because he
obviously is a part of the Teen Shadows
technique to sumon this being it's
slightly different unlike hand signs or
signals with others all you need to do
with mahara is extend both arms forward
on top of this an incantation is
required to bring him forth and begin
the ritual this Bean though is by far
the most powerful shami available to be
summoned by someone with this tin
Shadows technique however no one in the
history of the zenan family has ever
been able to force it to submit unlike
all other shikami mahara is equipped
with its own kind of techniques firstly
this stud is armed with a weapon called
The Sword of extermination this blade is
attached to the shami's forearm and
enveloped in positive curs energy making
it especially effective against cursed
Spirits secondly the beam possesses the
ability to adapt to any and all
phenomena how this works is that say if
it's injured by a particular attack the
e-hand wheel will turn allowing mahara
to adapt this can take up to a few spins
depending on just how in depth the
technique is trying to adapt is after
all of these spins needed to adapt
complete mahara will be able to counter
it this also works offensively as well
allowing mahara to figure out a way
around the technique so he's able to
deal damage third of the series main
Trio nobara kugisaki the country girl
actually boasts large reserves of curs
energy and is an expert at manipulating
it to her will this isn't specifically
mentioned in the anime or Manga but in
the fan book we learn where noara got
her ability from like Mami the straw
doll technique is passed down inside of
the kugisaki family with no Barra
specifically inheriting the technique
from her grandmother the straw doll
technique incorporates a tool set that
features a hammer nails and straw doll
Effy that has has the ability to greatly
improve the user's curse energy by
channeling her curse energy through the
tools nobara can utilize a number of
different techniques including sharing
damage between her straw doll and her
Target these nails are sent into the
user's Target using a hammer to hit and
propel them forward as projectiles the
curse energy allows the nails to be
freely manipulated giving the user free
range of motion in preparation for that
said strike if the target is hit by the
nails the curse energy flowing through
them can be used to deal even further
damage once hitting a Target the user of
straw doll manipulation can use an
extension technique the first of these
is resonance which applies cursed energy
to the user's Target using a straw doll
as an effigy the user will generally use
one body part of their target to create
the link and then use resonance to apply
damage to more critical appendages of
the opponent's body for example by
placing a curse technique s arm on the
straw doll and striking it with a nail
using a hammer the nails can be used to
Pier the targeted cursor's heart the
effectiveness of this technique VAR iies
on the opponent's skill level the
targeted body part and the strength of
the connection to the user's Target if a
link is made to multiple opponents
resonance will injure them all at the
same time the second and last extension
technique we've seen from the straw do
technique hapin allows the user to
greatly enhance the output of your curse
energy curse energy shrouding the nails
will expand with explosive force highly
magnifying their destructive
capabilities I think this works by
placing some sort of binding Val on the
nails that means they'll be destroyed
after the technique is used moving forth
and I'm going to stick junip thing in
here cuz I didn't really know where to
stick him elsewhere in the video and I
guess he he kind of would have been a
first gear either way junip shikami Moon
DRS takes the form of a translucent Blue
Jellyfish with a body large enough to
cover its user it has two black eyes and
thin yellow tentacles draping from its
body moon drgs is capable of reshaping
its tentacles as well as portions of its
body to form Stingers it's also capable
of hitting people with poison and its
attacks
so next up Kyoto jiujitsu Tech actually
has a first year in aratan this dude
isn't by any means a physical fighter
and is more seen as a coordinator type
of like sorcerer to be honest he reminds
me of a manager probably just due to
like the black suit that he wears
throughout the uh story his ability
though painkiller is a technique that
allows Arata to stop existing injuries
from getting any worse the user of
painkiller can't specifically heal
wounds but they can stop bleeding and
reduce the pain for anyone it's apply to
the downside of this technique is mainly
how it doesn't allow the user to heal
anyone just sustain their injuries
moving forward now out of the first
years and onto the first of the second
years at Koto
Tech my zen who doesn't actually possess
an inherited technique like the majority
of other characters however she does
have her own one that she created over
time this technique is also seen in
another character called yodu that makes
her appearance during the Cen game so
we'll speak a little B bit about that
here this ability construction is an
inefficient technique that consumes most
of the users cursed energy to create
something from nothing andlike creating
objects with a domain things constructed
by this technique will not disappear
once the spell is finished however
creating something from nothing uses an
immense amount of curse energy cuz you
know you've got to have drawbacks from
creating something out of absolutely
nothing which obviously results in a
harsh backlash on the user's body so
depending on how much curse energy the
user of this ability might have it will
allow them a differing level and
complexity of things they might be able
to
create sadly for my and her pathetically
small pole of curse energy all she was
able to produce is a single bullet per
day I should bring it up as well but my
was also able to create a curse tool
sword at the cost of her own life some
of the cooler extension techniques
though that we have seen from
construction come from yodu and her
battle against the king of
curses first of those liquid metal is
pretty much how it sounds a construction
of liquid metal that's changeable in
shape and volume with stable physical
properties due to like the
semi-autonomous curse energy that's
manipulating it this ability here almost
works as like a base for the
construction technique to build other
things off of for example the user of
this technique could use the liquid
metal to create an insect armor which is
specialized in adapting to a plethora of
different insects abilities and
functions doing this will inherently
help with sustaining the user curs
energy for a longer period of time while
simultaneously enhancing their speed
strength and
durability lastly a user of construction
is one of the only beings able to make a
perfect sphere by using that liquid
metal and shaping it into a sphere the
user is able to make a perfect one a
true sphere has no contact area and
generates infinite pressure as a result
making it absolutely Untouchable it's
kind of like Gojo's Hollow purple and
the idea that it's an Unstoppable
imaginary mass of curse energy that will
destroy absolutely anything in its path
next up on the food chain of abilities
inside of jiujitsu kaisen comes from the
traitor himself kichi muta so we kind of
have a similar ability to Kiki's puet
manipulation and masami's curse corpse
manipulation but they are inherently
different unlik likee mamichi who can
give the doll control kichi himself
controls these puppets with his Adept
use of curse energy sorry Mary but
because I'm mentioning a Heavenly
restriction now I tell I'll mention you
at all throughout this video so you know
I'll chucker in here with this here this
heavenly restriction is a restriction
placed on someone and not a technique a
person will perform themselves it is
explained to us is a binding that is
placed upon a sorcerer's body when they
are born I'm not sure if this is an
otherworldly uncontrollable feat or
something the parents perform themselves
what we do know is that these bindings
usually refer to limitations on the
human body this could be cursed energy
related or physically related in
exchange the person with this
restriction receives improved
capabilities kichi who suffers from an
extreme example of heavenly restriction
was gifted with vast amounts of cursed
energy that he used to control massive
amounts of mamaru Puppets remotely
through puppet manipulation puppets such
as ultimate mamaru are capable of using
explosive curse energy blasts that look
like plasma beams among a bivvy of other
abilities I should mention this as well
even though I feel like it's more of a
barrier technique since it's related to
The Shadow style but miwa possesses the
ability called BTO sword drawing this
ability is an IIA or EA I don't know how
to say that word there soldering
technique optimal for striking enemies
situated directly in front of the user
it covers the blade with curse energy
and rotates it greatly improving the
Drone
speed so the next second here who
actually has an inherited technique is
the mute Legend big inaki to and his
cursed
speech
C speech is an inherited technique
of the inumaki family it reinforces the
users word words with cursed energy
which compels The Listener to act or be
acted upon based on those words to
execute cursed speech the user must use
a curse toll with a particular set of
sales on it for example the mute King
has sale markings on his cheeks and
tongue whereas the original MC UTA has a
tool created by the anaki family the
serpent eyes and Fang which has those
same markings on it Cur speech is
activated when the user utters words or
commands alloud that are reinforced with
curse energy this action as I've said
compels The Listener to act or be acted
upon as a command for example a curs
speech user can command his opponent to
stop moving or for them to be crushed
the strength of his ability entirely
depends on the skill of the user as Cur
speech uses language and as a more wild
technique it can make it dangerous to
casually speak with other people
civilians and anyone within the range of
the user will be affected if they
accidentally hear the wrong word as a
countermeasure users of cursed speech
tend to limit their casual language to
certain safe words words to avoid
triggering cursed
speech back when I first mentioned
masamichi I didn't really know if I
should include this cuddly bear as a
part of his cursed corpse manipulation
or have Panda as his own person with his
own techniques obviously I've decided
the latter as this person is 100% his
own person with his own abilities and
feelings like we all saw that Panda's
cry due to him being a puppet panda
panda didn't exactly have the ability to
inherit a technique however he instead
possesses what's called cursed corpse
cores inside of him are three cores all
with differing personalities and Powers
Panda's body the balanced in main form
the power form called gorilla mode and
the third core called Triceratops mode
at base Panda technically has three
lives but if any of these cores are
damaged pandas unable to shift into that
form until it
recovers by switching to his brother's
core and going Gilla mode Panda can
transform into a muscular gorilla panda
is much stronger and faster in this form
but at the cost of rapidly draining his
curse energy a secondary technique
available while in gorilla mode un
blockable drumming beat allows any
strike Panda lands to resonate through
the target's body the idea behind this
is similar to yuji's Divergent fist
punch and watch even if the person
blocks they still feel some sort of like
secondary damage resonate through
them finally by switching to his
sister's big core Panda can transform
into Triceratops mode apparently this is
the most destructive form but as we
haven't seen much from her so far all we
can do is take Panda's word for it Panda
apparently claims his sister's form
destroys everyone who looks at her
because of her shyness however the one
time she did turn up it didn't exactly
go too well for
her ah now we get to talk about the
ability thief the Kakashi wannabe of jjk
the original MC Mar's girl big UTA aotu
and the plethora of abilities that this
gu got stored up while connected to R
through his ring UT can fully manifests
the queen of of curses this is called a
complete ra manifestation ra also has
the ability to sort a wide range of
curse tools and can equip them to UTA at
well there is a time limit on her full
manifestation though as he can only
maintain a sustained connection with ra
and remain in the state for 5 minutes at
a time I'm assuming this is because the
ring is like a doorway to whatever realm
the unreeled ra now abides in while
connected to ra UTA can actually copy
andate techniques of other people and
use them for himself he can even use
multiple different techniques that is
copied in quick succession plus once
copying the wall rer is out he can use
those same abilities again whenever he
wants the conditions under which he can
copy a technique are not fully known but
it is implied that he gained the ability
to copy Oro Sky manipulation after ra
consumed her arm so far out of the ones
that we have seen UT has been able to
copy cursed speech Sky manipulation and
than ice
Breer on top of that UDA can only fire a
directed blast of curse energy when ra
is completely manifested this is
obviously called The Curse energy blast
and together they can fire a beam that
is just shy of matching ryu's Granite
blast putting oro's abilities aside cuz
we're going to speak more on them later
you can also summon shikami using his
hair as an intermediary the shikami
appear as small bats with heads similar
to that of rers they fly around the
opponent to form a sphere likee domain
that can slash anyone inside of it also
and just in case you thought this was an
ability that UT to had like created
you'd have copied this technique again
off that uh Dro Lu dalala dude anyway so
that's all of these second years from
both schools covered now and I guess we
better touch on the big dogs the
seniors hakari hakari hakari now I
initially thought I was going to be here
for a year trying to explain the Celio
technique then I realized it's his
domain I don't even have to worry about
that aari's innate technique is still
called private Pure Love Train this is a
chenko theme technique that is primarily
applied through his domain expansion the
C technique imbued into the domain
manifests private pure love train a
pachenko game inspired by the previously
mentioned romance manga series however
the reason I bring it up as a solo
technique is because hakari can actually
summon the visual effect indicators of
the game such as the shutter doors
outside of his domain they can then be
used to like catch block or even damage
the opponents that he's facing next up
and uh a big lover of the fever
Kara hosi has probably one of those
techniques that just make your brain rot
with confusion like how in the world do
you even think this one up this
technique named love rev Vu assigns five
stars with a Southern Cross shape in
order to Target curse energy the five
stars are aay a Croc Mimosa Ganan and G
in order to Mark something with a star
the user must make physical contact with
someone's curse energy anyone that has
been marked will experience a sparkling
light above their head when they
technique is activated they can also
find the name of the star they've been
marked with written somewhere on their
body only one star can be placed on one
person's curse energy at a time but the
same star can be applied to multiple
different people simultaneously this
also includes the user so if they've
marked themselves with a star they must
remove it before then deciding to Mark
another object if the user needs to mark
multiple different objects with stars
the objects need to be charged by
someone else's curse energy beforehand
curse energy shared between a sorcerer
and and the shikami is considered the
same by l r de Vu the user can Mark both
the shikami owner and the shikami with
the same star at the same time they can
even place a star on the sorcerer
without touching him directly simply by
making contact with the shami if this
happens the one with the higher curse
energy output will pull the other when
attracted anyone marked where a star
must follow a specific order if they
want to attempt moving towards another
star if they don't follow the orderings
targets with the same star will attract
each other making it impossible to to
escape the determined route that you
have to follow works by following the
nearest star first and finishing at the
furtherest one away the order that we
have seen is amay Acra Mimosa Ganan and
G which if you guys also want to look
online are the names of real stars and
I'm pretty sure that is also like in
sequence of closest to furtherest away
from Earth also if someone is marked
like with Mimosa you know like you can
you just have to go to Gar and then G
Crux to get out you don't have to go
back to amay then go all the way
through to get away from the mindbending
spatial abilities and move onto
something a little bit more down to
earth now Momo nishima is equipped with
an innate technique called to
manipulation along with other broom
related things this technique grants the
user the ability to levitate the tool
fly on the tool or create gusts of winds
imbued with curse
energy an extension of tool manipulation
winde is used by swinging the user's
broom as they ride it this can
effectively create strong gusts of curse
energy infused W strong enough to push
people back or even wound
them do you feel it brother I tell you
an arm is merely a decoration but the
act of Applause is the acclamation of
the Soul itself himothy big Toto has one
of the most simplistic abilities inside
of the verse but oh my Lord can he abuse
the absolute hell out of it and it's
freaking fantastic to
watch boogy Wy the body switching
ability activates when the user claps
their hands together the technique
switches the position of the user and
anything they desire all they need to do
is make sure whatever they intend to
switch has some level of curse energy a
user of this ability doesn't actually
just have to switch themselves as well
as they can also swap other people's
locations as long as they have curse
energy that is kind of all we know about
Boogie Wy there really isn't much to it
like some of the other abilities out
there another one of these highly
complex abilities comes from a Joo you
could almost call Father and Son the
blood manipulation of narutoshi c and
the big bro
choso as it implies blood manipulation
is a curs technique that allows the user
to control and shape their blood Beyond
its natural form or motion for a variety
of effects it can be used to manipulate
every aspect of the user's blood
including composition internal blood
flow plasma pulse rate body temperature
and red blood cells it also allows them
to control the blood outside of their
body as long as it belongs to the uh
user external blood can be hardened or
shaped to create mid-range projectiles
as any curse technique blood
manipulation efficiency and strength
depend on who wields it with this
technique we've seen two vastly
different people use it in my opinion
and due to him being human naroi C's use
of blood manipulation falls short to
that of choso this here is mainly for
the fact that the user is limited by the
amount of their own blood they have
access to too much blood loss could
obviously result in death so users of
this ability generally prepare blood
bags or weapons dipped in their own
blood in advance unless you know you're
choso and you're built completely
differently also another factor of blood
manipulation is that the blood is
poisonous to curse
Spirits the first of many extension
techniques flowing red scale increases
the users's body temperature pulse rate
and the number of red blood cells to
give themselves greatly increased energy
and physical
capabilities flowing red scale stack
intensifies flowing red scale in order
to increase the users physical
capabilities to an even higher degree
than
normal third of this techniques
extension techniques Crimson binding
transforms blood into a widespread net
that tightly ins snares the
target slicing exorcism is a long range
attack that allows the user to slice or
shoot their opponent it can take the
form of a quickly rotating disc of blood
or a long stream of blood convergence is
a baseline technique within blood
manipulation this technique is mainly
used first in combination with others to
perform an extension technique
convergence is achieved when blood is
compressed and condense to its limit
between the palms of the user from that
a compressed blood sphere will be formed
because it takes time to apply
convergence to blood the user is
vulnerable against fast and quick
attacks after using convergence a few
options are available for a blood
manipulation user one of these piercing
blood applies that compressed blood and
uses it in a longrange beam of blood
that will pretty much go through
anything it touches once skillfully
reinforced with curse energy it can
reach the speed of sound however any
subsequent movement will cause it to
slow this ability is so deadly that if
you do get hit by it without expecting
the attack you will be pierced
through another option available after
using convergence is Supernova to do
this the user will create small orbs of
blood then have those orbs shoot out in
every direction like a buck shot these
smaller orbs of blood are somewhat
hardened before they explode adding to
the damage that someone might
receive a quick utilization of blood
manipulation ability to hien blood blood
age Str strengthens the user's blood
density by rotating it at a high
speed using some of those same
properties blood meteorite is used when
they use a Harden some of their blood to
an almost crystallized level before
throwing it at their target it's most
lethal within short ranges as the speed
will drastically decrease over time
moving on from one minute perat to
another though sugu GTO and then
subsequently kinjaku have both been seen
in use of this
technique as the name suggests Cur
Spirit manipulation is a technique where
like the ten Shadows technique one can
control a being and this example a
cursed Spirit they were able to conquer
and battle rather than exercise the
cursed Spirit the user can absorb them
into a small black sphere before
consuming them orally consuming this orb
gives the user complete dominance over
the curse allowing them to summon them
at any time in the future if the
difference in grade is two levels or
more the curse manipulator can absorb
the curse spirit with practically no
conditions attached the user can extract
the curse technique from semi grade 1
and a above curs spirits that they
absorb providing them with an immense
arsenal of potential different moves
however the quality of the curs spirits
techniques ceases to grow from the
moment they are absorbed and the user
can only use that technique once for
example this is what kaku's plan was
during chabuya the growth of mjo to such
a high degree that it could absorb him
and use a Countrywide Idol
Transfiguration starting the culling
game like I mentioned before cper
manipulation operates functionally the
same as shikami Conjuring however no
intermediate Theory like a hand sign is
required there doesn't appear to be any
limits on the number of curses that can
be absorbed and it is unknown what
happens to the curse Spirits taken in
after the user
dies a possible way to rid oneself of
all of those curses though is through
the user's maximum technique usaki this
ability takes all of the curs spirits
that the user of curs spirit
manipulation has absorbed and merges
them all into one initially I thought
this was a beamlike ability but usumaki
itself takes the form of a swirling
curse spirit that levitates behind the
user once Unleashed it darts forward to
whatever was targeted and unleashes a
powerful attack of super condensed curse
energy moving forward again and I didn't
know this before doing some research but
mimo's technique ttty noose allows her
to hang her targets using a noose hence
you know like those hung managers
throughout shabuya that we've seen
although the exact mechanics of how it
works is unknown mimo's technique
involves the usage of both the rope and
her stuffed childhood toy that she keeps
on her one of the modern implementations
of a curse technique is SE when nanako
tries to use her phone and snap a
picture of sakuna nanako's technique
camera phone allows her to manipulate a
photographed subject that she takes an
image of using the camera on her cell
phone she once used this ability on
herself to dodge one of jer's attacks
but the process tied her out quickly and
it's unknown how this technique even
exactly
works so the only member from the cursed
User Group Q to have an ability that we
might somewhat know as buer and those
knives of his I'm calling this ability
knives out cuz it sounds dop ha but I'm
assuming that it's some sort of tall
manipulation like ability in which you
can freely manipulate knives with curse
energy moving out of Q now and onto the
professional Sorcerers I think it's
fitting that with the very first
professional Sorcerers techniques that
we go over we start with a model example
of what a grade one jiutu sorcerer is
the big man can turn an army and his
ability to ratio the absolute hell out
of anyone he comes
across a user of ratio technique is able
to mark the Target's body with lines
divided into tths if the user is able to
strike one of these lines on exactly the
7 to3 ratio point they deliver a
critical hit to the subject this allows
them to deal significant damage on
strong opponents and absolutely body the
hell out of anyone weaker than them
these figurative lines don't actually
have to measure up to the full targets
length height or wingspan their head
torso biceps and forearms are all areas
that someone with this technique can
individually Target on top of that the
technique doesn't have have to be used
on curses or people and can even be used
on inanimate objects like
buildings the only extension technique
that we've seen a user of ratio ability
use is collapse instead of a singular
Target collapse expands the overall
Target area of what can be hit by the
ratio technique simply it creates a wake
point in the surrounding environment
allowing the user to deliver a critical
hit and destroy it the impact of this
technique is so powerful it creates
shock waves of curse energy that rips
through its effective hit Zone that
anyone wondering why I haven't mentioned
overtime and revealing one's hand well
those are just binding vales and I'll go
over the binding VES in another separate
video extremely fitting to stick these
two people next to each other and their
abilities as this guy here Tuma Eno I'm
pretty sure was either some kind of
student or friend in n armi in the past
before becoming a professional sorcerer
himself even now he still insists that
nanami is the only person to recommend
him for the role of grade
one takuma's technique though auspicious
Beast summon is extremely interesting as
it plays on the idea of summoning a soul
from another world the ABS is a type of
science technique that when the user's
face is hidden from view transforms them
into a spiritual medium for that beast
from what we've seen people with this
technique can bring forth the power of
the auspicious beasts numbers 1 through
4 each of the beast's abilities are
manifested by the user's curse energy
and can be summoned by calling out the
desired beast's name and number unlike
shami or cursed Spirit manipulation
auspicious Beast summon does not create
spirits to fight alongside their Master
instead the abilities of the auspicious
beasts are materialized through curse
energy for the user to utilize
themselves auspicious Beast number one
kaii summons a horn with a spiral
pattern on it it can be fired as a
homing projectile cloaked in curse
energy that won't stop until it hits its
Target the second auspicious Beast Reiki
or raiki I I don't know covers Eno's
body in curse water that can be used to
cushion him from danger and or increases
overall
Mobility auspicious Beast number three
Kon pretty much allows the user to fight
with a massively reduced sense of pain
this will drain the user stamina
simultaneously making them extremely
tired but completely unable to fall
asleep once the Beast has been summoned
and whatever was needed to be done as
completed the user won't be able to
function for a limited amount of time
we've never actually seen the use of
this Beast so I've only been able to go
off what Eno said about its powers here
another of the beasts that we really
haven't seen But know a little about
auspicious Beast number four Ryu was
about to be used in Eno's battle against
the sance user however toi zenan got his
ass up to that point nobody had ever
survived to tell the tale after fighting
Ryu and once again that's according to
Eno though so I guess we have to go off
his word there time for big sis and the
creepy brother that follows her around
everywhere man is absolutely desperate
of course I'm talking about mayay and
her dope ability called Black bird
manipulation so as you've seen Blackbird
manipulation allows the user to imbue
Crows with curse energy and control them
at well I'm not sure if it's
specifically crows but it does seem that
way from what we've seen the user of
this ability can manipulate multiple
crows at the same time Additionally the
user can also share Vision with the
birds making the technique perfect for
surveillance the crows that have been
imbued with curse energy are under
absolute control so if needed they can
be used to strike the opponent even at
the cost of the own bird life so that
brings us to one of the extension
techniques we've seen mayay use with
Blackbird
manipulation bird strike in order to
exceed the limits of the normally weak
crows a blackbird manipulator can force
their crows to commit no life by hurling
a crow imbued with curse energy Beyond
its normal limit a user can unleash a
devastating attack that is normally a
oneit finisher apparently and according
to mayay the only person that's ever
been able to stop it is
Gojo when it comes to we Wei the
specifics of his andate technique are
absolutely unknown they may said that
allowed them to both escape the battle
by transferring them from Japan to
Malaysia so I'm Legit just going to go
ahead and say that there is some form of
teleportation or Gateway like ability
adding more Credence to this his
technique also allowed him to act as
someone who could communicate with
people inside and outside of the
barriers during the King game which is
you know impossible for other people
someone who doesn't Capt in the
slightest though and even decided to
mentally ruin Sugo ghetto with talking U
then beat the ass out of the guy who
stole his body of course I'm talking
about the queen herself and most
powerful professional sorcerer the
special grade Yuki sukumo and her star
R first thing I need to mention is that
this technique has a shikami called
Garuda associated with it it's 100% a
part of the technique so I'm just going
to label it as a kind of extension for
her gruda can have virtual Mass added to
it using star rage as it's the only
thing affected by the curse technique
other than the user what makes it even
more confused using cuz it's like is
this a a curse tool or a shikami is that
star rage transforms Garuda into a curse
tool that the user can then use in
battle gruda can also act and fight
independently regardless whether or not
star rage is actually active so I'm
assuming that it obviously is a
shami when it comes down to like her
main technique star rage the primary
function of it is to empower its user
with the ability to add Mass to
themselves and the shikami associated
with this technique the mass added is
virtual or imaginary but it always
increases the users physical attacks
with force equal to the real Mass
assigned to them the added Mass doesn't
weigh down the user or chicagami but it
also doesn't increase their body's
overall weight as well however there is
a density threshold to how much virtual
or imaginary Mass the user can stack on
themselves if it's taken too far and
they add way too much mass or like
density to themselves it will condense
their body into a black hole with
extreme gravity ripping everything
around into it this is like no question
one of the strongest abilities in this
series and it just sucks that we never
got to see it used in more than two
battles plus the first time that it did
show up at the end of shabuya it's kind
of like hard to call that a battle for
Star as well because it kind of just was
there it didn't do
anything moving on to the zenen family
now and when it comes to their household
they're meant to be known for the 10
Shadows technique however none of the
main fames current family members were
born with that inherited technique
instead naoo and naoya had a secondary
inherited technique projection
sorcery just like in an anime sequence
movie or animation this technique
divides one second into 24 frames of
Animation using the user's field of view
as a projection angle to perform the
ability the user will trace a
predetermined set of movements that take
place over 24 frames and execute them in
a single second due to how this
technique works it makes the user appear
to move unnaturally fast too quick for
even special grade curse sprits to
follow however this is technically just
a the fallacy while projection sorcery
is active and the Sorcerer is in
movement anything touched by the user's
Palm must also abide by the 24 FPS Rule
and copy those same movements if the
opponent doesn't follow those specific
rules it results in the subject getting
immobilized and Frozen in an animation
frame for 1 second although it's just a
second anything caught in that frame is
completely vulnerable to attack allowing
people to land free hits on it hitting
the frame will break the target out of
it catching someone in the frame won't
do any damage to them in itself so the
sorcerer using this ability still needs
to somewhat be physically strong after
the user decides on their movements the
predetermined course cannot be adjusted
on top of that if the trajectory of
movements or the laws of physics are
excessively ignored the user will be
frozen in a frame for one
second next up and brother tooo oi zenan
always thought he was unlucky and hard
done by in life he never received the
ten Shadows technique or projection
sorcery and was always outclassed by his
older brother still somehow he thought
that he was the one who deserved to be
the hi the family and that's why I think
he decided to name his innate technique
blazing
courage blazing courage allows the user
to ignite flames of curse energy and
channel them through their weapon to
create a flaming sword blazing courage
can be used to replace a broken blade
and can even slice through objects as a
sword word if the user infuses more
curse energy into the technique it will
generate scorching Flames that encircle
them and coat their
blade next up out of people instead of
the zenan clan with some form of
technique so don't expect to hear about
the kuoo squad anytime soon R zenan and
his paralyzing gaze pretty much from
what we could see paralyzing gaze is an
ability that catches anyone the user
gazes upon in an immobilizing aura on
top of that large eyes that admit the
paralyzing gaze are imagined behind the
opponent these eyes work as an
intermediary between the Sorcerer And
opponents so if someone managed to break
the hold and in turn those eyes it could
backfire with with devastating
consequences next up out of these Zen
janichi and his massive missile fists
technique as the name implies missile
fists is an extremely destructive
technique in which the user is able to
conjure a number of giant fists that are
propelled by cursed energy like a
missile lastly out of the zenan family
members chojo zenan and his ability to
manipulate the
Earth Cho's Earth arms technique allows
him to manipulate the Earth to some
degree to do this the user touches the
ground with both hands and activates the
ability from what we've seen this
ability do it's only able to create
large stone hands but I'm sure there's
probably some more utility to it that we
never got to
see moving on from the zenen and when it
comes to the king of curses himself it's
currently unknown what zuna's curse
technique is called throughout the
series he's been shown to use his curse
energy to perform two types of slashes
the reason we don't know if this is his
innate technique or not is because he
has such a high level of of control over
curse energy most characters will take
days to unlock a new ability for sakuna
though all it takes is one glance at how
it was achieved to do it himself on top
of the base standard slashing attack
sakuna was seen using he's also been
shown to use Fire based powers that
originate from another
dimension when it comes to the slashing
attacks though dismantle is an attack
that is normally used for inanimate
objects the attack doesn't work on curs
Spirits or Sorcerers unless they are no
longer considered alive it may also work
on Mary as curse energ sees her as an
inanimate
object secondary of the two slashes
cleave is in an attack that adjusts the
level of curse energy needed depending
on the target's toughness to cut them
down in one
go possibly another otherworldly ability
or even has innate technique fire arrow
is an ability that allows the user to
open some form of black box to create
and manipulate Flames these Flames are
then formed into an arrow and shot at
whoever the intended target is
throughout the series not a single
person even even though it's only been
shot once I guess has ever survived
these
Flames after gaining megami's body we
saw the king of curses use a multitude
of new abilities that we hadn't seen him
use before the first of these spiderweb
allows the user to utilize cleave but in
a spiderweb like pattern as a variation
of cleave this technique can also adjust
its destructive force to take out the
intended opponent or surroundings in one
blow when it comes to the 10 Shadows
technique sakun actually expanded on
what we originally knew was even
possible he made the technique makes him
otherworldly and even summoned other
shikami we never saw meami H up the
first of these ancient shikami pacing Ox
as as the name says an ox shami that can
charge down opponents with frightening
speed due to how we've seen it summoned
it can only move in a straight line but
the longer its charge the more powerful
its hits will be it's also extremely
robust and was able to take a few blows
from a special grade here in Period
sorcerer before
Vanishing second is the round deer this
Beast is a towering dear shikami that
can automatically heal itself and the
master through reverse curse technique
the positive curse energy that flows
through the shikami is powerful enough
to cause another sorcerer to lose
control of whatever they might be doing
of course as well with it like being
positive energy and like mahara I say
that round a is also a great option for
battling cursed
Spirits lastly out of the extra adding
to the 10 Shadows technique unless you
want to like talk about what he did with
freaking NE way over there is an
improved humanoid version of no way
again this emerged aito inherit of the
powers of the Great Serpent tiger
funeral and round deer it is a large
powerful shikami capable of producing
electricity and regenerating lost limbs
with reverse curse technique this
reverse curse technique can you know
just like uh the deer work on its Master
also I might as well mention this here
but we did technically get the 10th suar
gami revealed to us it's name tiger
funeral doesn't really give much away
apart from the fact that it's got
something to do with a tiger and there
were some tiger-like markings on aito so
yeah moving over to the oldest lady in
the history of jutu Kaizen big thuman
being the oldest person in the verse
Tangen has the ability of immortality
this technique obviously grants the user
eternal life however it does not stop
the aging process in order to keep
living past this point their body and
technique must be reseted every 500
years hence what happened throughout the
goou past
Arc moving on to the previous lover of
tingen and the back but King kinjaku has
been around for as long if not longer
because of his special ability body
swapping kaku's inate technique allows
him to swap bodies with another person
even if they are dead by transplanting
his brain into the body of his Target
after the transplant is complete this
technique leaves a stetched scar running
across the user's head the user is at
any time able to remove the top part of
the head and reveal their true self as
well once inside a body the user of body
swapping will gain access to the boasts
curse energy all of their inate
techniques and memories even these six
eyes won't be able to recognize him as
an impostor since he is the original
users curse energy as shown with his
usage of kori's technique while fighting
against choso and Yuki it's been hinted
that even when switching to a new body a
body swapping user retains access and
usage of his former host innate curse
techniques this can't be abused too much
though as the limit of former host and
eight techniques the user can store is
up to four and kenju was only able to
store for because like his technique is
a brain you know so he's able to do more
than most people one of these stolen
inate techniques from a former host the
anti-gravity system is freaking broken
and probably probably my favorite
ability in this series cuz it's Gravity
the exact function of how K Ori itadori
technique worked still isn't fully
explored so it's hard to exactly pin
down on how kaku's version of it might
work but what we all need to understand
is that what we saw him use is the
reversal of her curse technique in
theory I'm assuming that kori's
anti-gravity turned off the gravity
around her and allowed the user to send
people shooting off in some sort of
vacuum what we saw was the reversal of
it where the user instead forces and
insane amount of gravitational forces
down for approximately 6 seconds on top
of that the gravitational forces don't
seem to affect the user but are able to
stop the effects of pretty much any
ability including a freaking black hole
this ability just because of like how
unknowing it is still seems so
interesting to me and I'd love to get
another feat in an upcoming battle so we
can find out more on it the fact that
this could be an ability that Yuji could
possibly have in the future because his
mom had it as well is mental like is it
possible dude could go from having no
abilities to just being stacked up with
like two or three different innate curse
techniques because of how his body is
structured I'd love to know your
thoughts on this one down below for sure
and if you think I'm misunderstood
please be sure to let me know because
this technique is pretty mind
buling sticking with uh the other
members of kaku's squad and someone who
actually turned out to be aun's close
acquaintance the ice queen arume has one
of the most versatile abilities in the
series ice formation as you could
imagine this ice based technique allows
the user to lower the temperature around
them to extreme levels these freezing
temperatures then allow them to produce
ice and frost at well the user can
generate multiple sheets of solid ice by
simply touching a surface they can also
manifest other forms of ice such as a
cloud or frozen mist or a massive block
of ice that falls from the sky and ice
or extremely cold substance can also be
freely manipulated by the user a
baseline ability of ice formation Frost
Cal lowers the temperature of the air
around the user allowing them to Channel
A frosted Mist to their hand the user
then brings the hand up to their mouth
and blows on that Frozen Mist this in
turn creates a cloud of icy Mist that
shoots towards the target as The Cloud
of icy Mist moves forward anything that
it touches instantly gets frozen
enabling the user to trap their opponent
well trapped and covered in several
layers of ice one wrong move might
result in them getting cut by the razor
sharp icicles that now surround them
just like with the previous technique
ice full allows the user to lower the
temperature of the air around their hand
covering it with a thin layer of ice
with this extremely low temperature the
ice formation user is able to generate
massive amounts of ice on any surface
they touch on top of that the user can
break apart the ice using their mind and
levitate it through the air if they
manage to hit their opponent the user
can freeze their target on contact
covering their body with a thick layer
of hard ice once trapped again the
users's opponents are finished off by
large icicles that fly forth and skewer
their frozen
bodies next up on the list we got the
Creeper King himself big haruta shigyo
and his crazy innate technique
Miracles I think it's pretty obvious
here that gig needed someone to just
beat on for a little bit so we legit
created a technique that revolves around
Miracles the idea for this technique
works by erasing all of the little
everyday Miracles one might have like
seen a clock randomly hit all of these
same digits along with the memory of it
from the user's brain and stores them
away once stored away these lines appear
under the user's eyes with a maximum of
six Miracles being allowed per day these
stored up Miracles are released when the
user's life is in danger altering their
luck to ensure that they survive lethal
events finally when a miracle has been
used the markings turned to White
signify that it is
empty weirdly when it comes to the
people that can take a hit heat on and
make it seem as so they're absolutely
fine this old man jro aaka and his
averse technique is the perfect
example while activated inverse makes it
so that all damage against the user is
reversed simply enough strong blows
become weak and weak ones become strong
while the technique is activated due to
how ridiculous it would be if this
technique inversed everything that like
happened on the user there is a minimum
and maximum limit to these
conditions fourth and final from kaku's
group to have a no one technique oar
with her science technique came into
this story during shabuya and absolutely
flipped it on its head the science
technique grants the user the ability to
contact the dead and summon their body
or Soul's information to the Living
World this is done by having someone
consume a part of a deceased sourcerer
while the user performs a ritual behind
them transforming into someone using
their bod's information allows the shape
shifter to utilize their physical
abilities the technique is supposed to
Signal its own end when the shape
shifter's curse energy runs out however
there can be complications if the wrong
person is
resurrected once we entered the calling
game Mr gami decided to introduce a
flurry of new characters that have some
of the most exciting curse techniques
seen yet one of these guys and probably
the strongest
reincarnation hajim Kimo had a one usate
technique that would subsequentially end
his life once it finishes to enable
himself to fight without having to rely
on this technique the ancient sorcerer
took advantage of his unique electrified
curse energy
a side effect of his curse energy so
it's not really a curse technique but
lightning discharge works by applying a
positive charge to his Target the user
is then able to discharge the negative
charge without having any of their
electricity hit the ground in turn this
creates a powerful lightning like
ability that cuts through the sky and is
almost guaranteed to hit anyone in its
way the only way that actually Dodge is
if they could physically move faster
than lightning though so it's fairly
lethal and probably Gojo would be the
only person able to stop it with
infinity
when it comes to his one-time use innate
technique mythical Beast Amber it is a
Release Technique that reconstructs the
user's body in order to bring forth any
effect that can be created by
electricity once activated it can't be
deactivated and will use up all of the
curse energy that that user had as the
user's body will evolve into something
far beyond the human form there isn't
any specific extension ability connected
with its Attack Just side effects these
side effects increase the brain's
activity making it work faster optimize
sound and tuning waves to match normal
frequencies and vaporized radiated
objects using electromagnetic
waves next up we got the actual G
himself and yuji's new right-hand battl
man haromi hagara and his aate technique
deadly sentencing I can't actually wait
to see what happens like in the upcoming
manga with this so you'll know exactly
where I am right now just age this video
a little bit since deadly sentencing is
linked to the users domain expansion by
default I'll just slightly mention it
here if you want more I'll will make a
video going over re know domain
expansion binding vow and I've already
done barrier technique so you can check
that video out if you want right here
either way deadly sentencing manifest a
small courtroom domain surrounded by
Guillotines where the user and their
opponent are placed on Podium standing
across from one another this domain does
not use a guaranteed head instead anyone
inside is simply forced to follow its
rules continuing with the law type theme
of his domain it also incorporates a
shikami known as judgment who obviously
takes that judge role as it may suggest
deadly sentencing is a court-based
ability where the target is placed on a
stand and interrogated if found guilty
they could face a multitude of different
consequences what the worst being the
death
penalty on a lighter note though and
someone who's able to R the darkness
from people's hearts hanasu is able to
wield Angels innate technique known as
nullification pretty much this technique
is able to nullify any and all curses
including curse techniques barriers and
seals in addition the user might be able
to revert incarnated humans who whose
bodies have been fused with like curse
objects back to the original state there
are a lot of complications with this
though and it would most likely result
in the original vessel's body dying so
that's why you haven't seen it happen so
far when it comes to Hunter's maximum
output technique Jacob's letter this
ability cones a four-winged trumpet made
of light under the user's mouth then an
enormous magic circle of light in the
sky above the user's head this magical
Circle then features a large hypog gam
or seven-pointed star in the middle and
Crosses along its outer edge upon
sounding the trumpet theer creates a
beam of light that shoots down from the
middle of the circle to engulf whatever
is below any curse technique will be
extinguished under the lights and
Incarnation is also susceptible as
proven like when tuna's host body
started corroding you know under the
effects of this attack but you know who
who actually knows if he was just faking
it or not right there next up and we've
got the big man the legion himself big
fumo takaba and his insane annake
technique
comedian this technique is it's just
broken man in short it allows the user
to manifest whatever they think is funny
into reality like it's something that
can actually compare to Gojo's technique
it's that broken when you just think
this man can create anything he thinks
is funny and put it into reality the
effects of this technique cover a wide
variety including and like not being
limited to Conjuring objects or
substances from absolutely nothing
healing themselves without the use of
reverse curse technique and nullifying
Damage Done to them despite the
extraordinary power granted by this
technique comedian can only be activated
if the user remains confident and
certain in their ability to be funny as
a result if the user loses confidence in
their humor the technique will be
deactivated and render them vulnerable
to attacks time for the her extension
curse technique users hanu and
habba hu's curse technique airplane hair
changes the user hair into the shape of
a jet plane with two boosters strong
enough to propel someone through the air
at high speed just due to like how this
curse technique works and having all of
the Cur energy in their hair other
sections of their body are less
protected by curse energy and therefore
vulnerable while the technique is
activated just like hanu hub's curse
technique helicopter hair changed his
hair into a propeller with four Blades
by activating it a user of helicopter
hair can fly around and suspend
themselves in the air with ease they are
also able to adjust the length and angle
of their propellers as well as increase
its rotation speed and toughness like
hanu it's likely that hub's curse energy
is mainly focused on his hair making him
SU acceptable to body attacks as
well I actually completely forgot to add
this person into start with so luckily
on a second check through of all the
people I remember that Remy is actually
a part of the hair manipulation gang
with her scorpion here Remy's technique
scorpion here allows the user to
manipulate their hair into a
scorpion-like tail that can attack their
opponents sadly for users of this
technique it seems to be extremely weak
however that was probably just due to
like Remy's lack of curse energy as well
following the hair manipulat we've got a
man who's able to dupe the absolute hell
out of any receipts he finds no need to
buy anything when you've got registar
and his contractual Recreation technique
to just make it out of thin air for you
as the name suggests contractual
Recreation uses contracts such as
receipts to produce anything written on
them this manifests the main or most
expensive item on those receipts it can
produce pretty much anything written on
them but from what we have seen tends to
be the items or Services an item could
be anything from a TV to an axe whereas
a service might be a getaway Retreat or
a spa vacation that the user could
instantly activate and take the healing
effects from things the user recreate
sort of acts like a shikami with given
commands for example if someone summons
a few massage with a receipt the user
can order them with their mind to do a
certain action after they finish this
action though that summoning will
disappear and no longer be visible in
order to activate contractual Recreation
the user must apply their curse energy
to the contract or receipt and burn it
the downside to this technique is is
that water heavily debuffs the sorcerer
if they happen to get any of the
receipts wet then it will be almost
impossible to ignite them with curse
energy who I'm assuming could be
considered the second strongest sorcerer
inside of Reggie's group Yi has an okay
is an extremely durable character who
only recently kicked the bucket thanks
to kinjaku and you know I I didn't
actually get to include him in my old
death's video because he only died like
two weeks ago has noi's inate technique
explosive flesh allows him to remotely
detonate his own body parts and use them
as bombs to do this a user of the
explosive flesh technique can remove
parts of their body and throw them as
projectiles that will explode on command
to stop a user of this ability running
out of Limbs before they even make it
out of preschool a reverse curse
technique to replace the Lost body parts
makes it simple for a user of this
ability to regrow
anything most forgettable I'd say from
Reggie's group apart from maybe Remy
just due to how quickly mamy dunked on
this dude chisu harai has probably one
of the most useless techniques that
makes an appearance during the calling
game technique claws allows him to shift
his fingers into dark claws it's hard to
say if the offensive size of this
ability had any effects while fighting
as the dude really never got to show it
off pretty much all we got to see was
that users of this ability can also
climb walls using their claws which is
pretty damn
pathetic finally someone with a little
bit of potency again the legend himself
and man with the largest curse energy
output in the entire King game Ryu is
Shori ryu's technique curse energy
discharge is a pretty straightforward
technique it allows the user to
discharge directed beams of compressed
curse energy like a cannon and
preparation to fire the Blast has to be
charged up in order to build up a large
enough concentration of curse energy
into a singular point the strength of
the outputed blast depends on how much
time was allowed for it to build up then
finally once it does fire the beams can
take several forms depending on the
user's desires for example curse energy
can be fired as a full power blast
capable of decimating several set blocks
or a volley of multiple rapid blasts to
take out the user's
targets Granite blast is the most
powerful and straightforward application
of curs energy discharge it is a long
range extremely powerful blast wave of
highly concentrated curse energy that
can easily destroy an entire city block
the more cursed energy that is charged
into Granite blast the larger and more
deadly its attack range
becomes next up we've got the series
longest living hater and someone who
just can't seem to let things go takako
uro and into her Sky manipulation
technique it's been like 400 years and
the first thing she does each time she
sees some strong dude is accuse them of
being a Fuji wirus scumbag which you
know I love it's pretty funny either way
takako's technique grants her the
ability to control the sky hence Sky
manipulation a user of this ability can
turn the sky into a tangible surface and
use it to manipulate space similar to
like how a lens creates Distortion I'm
going to Chuck like this description in
here of like what Distortion exactly is
and how it works because it actually
helps with understanding this technique
a little bit more and these these images
also like give a great example
Distortion commonly occurs from
deviations or anomalies near the edge of
an image each type of distortion usually
develops through different variables
Barrel Distortion for example is often
the result of a lens at full zoom while
pinch cushion Distortion occurs most
often from telephoto lenses a user of
Sky manipulation can casually use it to
levitate themselves and hide behind
portions of manipulated sky in battle a
user can defend themselves but
distorting the shape of the sky around
their opponent's
attacks the surfac is that a sky
manipulator controls can't Crush anyone
directly so instead a user can break the
surface of the sky with an attack called
thin Icebreaker this ability creates a
shattering effect that cracks the
surface of the sky like thin ice and
hits the target with some form of
multiplied
Force lastly out of the cing game
players who were introduced and someone
who is in my opinion a gig katami self
insert Charles Bernard and his Manga
style technique G War
staff okay so again with like me being a
little bit confused over should I
include this or not cuz technically GW
stuff is a curse tool that is directly
tied to Charles's anate technique but we
continue on either way because it it
makes sense due to him being a Manger
the item is a long spear with a
pin-shaped tu by hitting their opponent
and getting some blood on the pin's tip
a user of this technique can fulfill the
conditions for ink after which they can
use their ink to mark their opponent
with a manga penel this penel is taken
directly from one second in the future
allowing the user to see their
opponent's upcoming actions if a user of
G War staff can draw more blood from
their opponent then it will increase the
amount of time they can peer into the
future moving on now from the techniques
that were introduced to us throughout
the calling game along with just those
Sorcerers in general in this last
section we will delve into all of the
techniques seen from cursed Spirits so
far inside of ji Jutsu Kaizen also I'm
pretty sure their only special grades
vengeful cursed spirits and the death
paintings have curse techniques so this
list isn't nearly as large as The Human
Side of Things starting things off
though and just due to them sharing a
bunch of techniques is the brothers ISO
and
kisu so both ISO and kisu possess the
rot technique this ability plays on the
curses dark and toxic blood simply it's
poisonous to humans and corrodes
anything it touches capable of burning
skin on impact and eating away at solid
rock this here is probably just due to
the Half Human Side being from the C
family and having that Affinity in their
blood to you know like hurt cursed
Spirits so now it's being reversed to
hurt humans additionally utilizing the
rot technique also grants the user the
ability to manipulate their blood in
various ways the blood can be shaped
into weapons or used to poison someone
and Decay their body over
time speaking of Decay Decay was a
technique both of the brothers possessed
this ability creates a floral pattern on
the Target that quickly begins eating
away at their body anyone who takes in
the blood of a rot technique user
through membranes or wounds can be
fected with this technique this can also
spread to other people if accidentally
touched Sorcerers or curse users who get
afflicted by this technique are said to
be killed in less than 15
minutes last of the cursed wors known
techniques Rock technique maximum Wing
King which was only seen from ESO
manipulates the user's blood and shapes
it into large wasp likee wings These
Wings can be used to create Paths of
blood which can be used for offensive
purposes or to increase the users's
maneuverability when the lines of blood
connects with their target they're
instantly burned by the corrosive
effects of the blood this in turn will
also afflict them with the Decay
technique when it comes through these
special grade curses some of them have
the most complex abilities in the
series one of those ganisha has a
technique that is able to Target
Concepts itself whatever the hell that
means just true to how short of a time
this curse was in the story The ins and
outs of how obstacle removal work isn't
exactly known Kaku described ganesha's
ability as the power to remove obstacles
and Target Concepts so I'm assuming that
the curse itself is probably able to
remove anything from an area and place
it in another along with targeting the
idea or concept behind a curse technique
for example kinjaku had the curse use
its removal ability to remove a bunch of
dudes blocking its path in the white
house then in its battle against Yuki
the curse tried to Target and remove the
concept of her technique however the
overwhelming Mass was too much and the
curse failed to do
so second of the known special grade
curses in the list kuroshi the cockroach
is an actually terrifying
Force Kur Roshi's curse technique cursed
cockroaches can produce and manipulate
countless swarms of real cockroaches
reinforced by its curse energy these man
eating cockroaches are able to strip the
Flesh of a group of humans in a matter
of second doing this actually feeds Kur
Roshi's endless appetite and in turn
stimulates his extension technique
pathogenesis Kur Roshi's pathogenesis
process grants the cursed Spirit the
ability to produce even more cockroaches
on top of that the curs spirit can use
process to reproduce an identical yet
entirely new curse Spirit however in
order to preserve the original
cockroach's existence the curse energy
from the parent is passed onto the child
when it dies and so on Last of The
cockroach's Knowing techniques Ann
insect trance allows the cursed Spirit
to conjure up flying insects that carry
large sex filled with a liquid substance
that gets released when destroyed if the
curs spirit opponent gets too like
sloppy when taking out one of these uh
little insects right here and the
substance does happen to get into the
target's eyes it will start to impair
the vision making it easier for the
curse to win third out of the no and
special grades small pox deity is one of
the stronger curses inside of kaku's
storage of Cur Spirits small pox deity's
curse technique gravestone begins when
it traps its Target inside a cramped
cofin after the target is caught the
curse takes its left Fist and lowers it
into its right hand this motion drops a
giant gravestone on top of the coffin
dealing heavy damage and burying the
coffin underground once the gravestone
is placed underground the disease curse
begins to count down from three if the
count reaches one the target will be
infected with a small pox and die it's
unknown how long it takes for the Target
to obviously die once infected but you
know it it will happen they will
eventually die Deon is one of the main
threats to make their appearance join
shabuya if it wasn't for toi showing up
it's likely that a few of the main group
could have died fighting this curse here
it's technique disaster Tides allows the
user to manifest High volumes of water
and control it using their curse energy
it can be used as a water shield for
close and mid-range and as a large
sweeping wave for long range combat its
efficiency is dependent upon the curse
energy of the user and for that reason
can only be utilized to its full
potential by someone adapt in curse
energy
manipulation weakest out of the disaster
curses but still special grade rank so
you know don't forget that Hanami is
equipped with a range of abilities that
if not taken seriously will deal serious
damage Hanami innate technique allows to
use it to form and control a variety of
cursed forer its abilities are normally
initiated with one's Mind by activating
the technique next to the intended
target or on the user themselves all of
the plants that make up disaster plants
are made from curse energy meaning that
all creations can be constructed and
deactivated instantly the technique also
grants the user the ability to absorb
the life energy from real plants they
can then take that energy turn it into
like a sort of flower offering and
finally convert it into curs energy that
they use can then use one of the main
Extinction techniques Roots can create
large tree roots that emerge from the
ground at well if an army decides to
limit the reach and number of rots made
the overall power and speed of the other
Roots will increase obviously this works
both ways and if an army also decides to
greatly expand the number of rots and
their range it will be at the sacrifice
of speed and the destructive power as
the name says wooden ball allows Han
armi to create a singular or multiple
wooden balls from curse energy these
wooden balls will then shoot out one or
two sharp Branch attacks in attempt to
skewer their target the disaster curse
is also able to use this technique to
suspend yourself in
midair the cursed bud is an attack that
launches flower buds that feed on the
curse energy of whoever it attaches to
the more techniques someone Afflicted
with a bud uses the deeper the bud Roots
will extend into their body fending off
more cursed energy there is like also
the option of spawning a large flower
that can shoot a massive barrage of
these cursed pods
the last technique that we saw Hanami
use flower Fields as the name would
suggest can create a circle of flowers
around their opponent that distracts
them with an effect that removes their
well to fight Hanami was also able to
use this technique remotely by launching
a long-range projectile that the ability
activate it off the only downside to
this ability is that if the user is
weakened then flow Fields won't be as
effective at removing the opponent's
well to
fight possibly the strongest out of the
disaster curses goat Cho or Cho goat is
equipped with a few techniques that
would put prettyy much any sorcerer
apart from Gojo on the back
foot the cursor's innate technique
disaster Flames allows the user to form
and control both fire and lava the
Flames are immensely powerful capable of
instantly killing non Sorcerers and
critically injuring Sorcerers these
Flames are visible to non Sorcerers and
also possess similar properties to real
Flames the technique also grants the
user the ability to telepathically
create miniature volcanoes on any
surface these volcanoes are capable
capable of firing powerful lava towards
the user's intended
target one of the first techniques we
saw a curse actually used in this story
imber insects allows Joo to summon small
flying insect like curses from the
volcanic opening and his head these
curses had a large Stinger that produce
a loud noise upon impact before
detonating into a flaming
explosion joo's maximum technique meteor
generates a gigantic flaming meteor that
the user is able to Hur at the targets
the meteor's size probably depends
entirely on how much curse energy the
curse is willing to like put into the
attack if this attack lands the impact
it causes is on a like completely new
level in terms of destructive force and
jutu kaisen it's without question will
destroy entire sections of a city and is
even strong enough to wound a 15 finger
sakuna knowing what I know now about
sakuna though I'm questioning if he was
just gasing Jo goat up or like not I'd
love to know your thoughts on it below
either way I think this is like
obviously what makes him the most potent
disaster curse getting towards Ward the
I guess the rear end of this video now
and on the final of four disaster curses
we have the maniacal Maniac himself
mahito as you all probably know this
dude was equipped with Idol
Transfiguration one of the most broken
abilities in Shonen imagine if he was
actually good for real this this dude
could have saved an entire Hospital of
kids or something idle Transfiguration
allows the user to reshape the soul of
themselves or anyone they physically
touch the shape of the body is dependent
on the shape of the Soul so if the soul
is distorted then the body will also
distort therefore someone using Idol
Transfiguration can disfigure their
Target's body into a hellish creature by
warping their soul shap with just one
touch this process creates what are
known as transfigured humans the only
way to block this technique is by being
physically built differently weak
Sorcerers stand absolutely zero chance
and even grade one Sorcerers will
transfigure after a touch or two first
of mjo's created techniques Soul
multiplicity which is kind of like a
base technique that others work workof
combines two or more Souls using idle
Transfiguration by slamming these two
Souls together it creates a reaction due
to the unnatural course of Soul Fusion
taking place this here as I mentioned
allows the user to derive more
techniques that take advantage of the
reaction one of these extension
techniques body repel takes advantage of
Soul multiplicity reaction by increasing
the energy of these Souls associated
with its effect the user can generate an
overwhelming wave of transfigured humans
that burst forth again utilizing Soul
multiplicity the user this time combines
all of his useless Souls with weak
rejection to create one body this body
in technique is called the polymorphic
Soul isomer a polymorphic soul isomer is
an attack based Transfiguration with
extremely deadly force however the
trade-off for its crazy strength is its
lack of durability a polymorphic salt
ismore can easily be killed with a
single Direct Hit using cursed
energy the instant Spirit body of
distorted Ken as a special self
Transfiguration that morphs the user
into a much much more powerful State due
to the nature of like Idol
Transfiguration and its connection to
the soul instant Spirit body of
distorted killing can only be achieved
when the user realizes the truest
essence of their being this technique
not only greatly Alters the users
appearance but also increases their
abilities granting them incredible
offensive and defensive
prowess finally last on the list of
Every curse technique inside of Jutsu
kaisen we've got the one vengeful curse
who has an ability that isn't a domain
expansion you know it's just a curse
technique curse naoya as a vengeful
cursed Spirit naoya somehow managed to
retain his innate technique but I've
decided to call it cursed projection
sorcery just to be you know edgy and
cool during his short time as a curse it
was shown to be greatly improved on by
his cursed spirit's body an extension
technique that he created as a cursed
Spirit acceleration mode allows a curse
to bring an ear through the inlets they
might have as they fly one can then use
the thrusting pressure and their own
curs energy to reject the ear out for an
increased speed this is a very specific
technique designed for the vengeful
naoya and I doubt anyone else would ever
be able to do something similar so that
there does officially bring us to like
the end of every single curse technique
in jiutu kaisen if you want me to make
like videos going over all of the
domains and all of like the cursed tools
inside of Jutsu Kaizen and all like
those kind of videos and stuff let me
know down in the comments section below
and I'd also love to know what your
favorite ability or curse technique
through atut to Kaizen could be is it an
innate technique like 10 Shadows or you
know is it something different it
actually comes from say a curse like the
the concepts one that ganish had which I
thought was pretty interesting or the
anti-gravity domain that uh Kori itadori
had which is another amazing domain I'd
love to know all your thoughts in in the
comments section below and if you can
smash a like on this video I've noticed
that for some reason now when you say
like it starts glowing around the like
button so just hit it for me and check
it out down below also subscribe that
thing glows too which is crazy YouTube's
updating heaps of features at the moment
that trying to trying to fix everyone
getting mad because they removing a
block which is crazy I can't believe
they're actually doing it by the way end
of the video I need to stop yarning on
for now it's been your professional
degenerate deolo and I will see you all
and a BS bye